there are some similarities between the
sequence the sequence machine
translation model and the language
models that you have worked with in the
first week of this course but there are
some significant differences as well
let's take a look so you can think of
machine translation as building a
conditional language model here's what I
mean in language modeling this was the
network we had built in the first week
and this model allows you to estimate
the probability of a sentence that's
what a language model does and you can
also use this to generate novel
sentences and sometimes we were writing
x1 and x2 here where in this example x2
would be equal to y1 or equal to Y hat 1
is just a feedback but X 1 X 2 and so on
weren't important so just to clean this
up for this slide I'm gonna just cross
these all right where X 1 could be the
vector of all zeros and X 2 X 3 are just
the previous output you were generating
okay so that was the language model the
machine translation model looks as
follows I'm going to use a couple
different colors green and purple to
denote respectively the encoding network
in green and the decoding network in
purple and you notice that the decoder
network looks pretty much identical to
the language model that we had up there
so what the machine translation model is
is very similar to the language model
except that Oh instead of always
starting along with the vector of all
zeros it instead has an encoding network
that figures out some representation for
the input sentence and then takes that
input sentence and starts off the
decoding network with a representation
of the input sentence rather than with
the representation of all zeros so
that's why I call this a conditional
language model and instead of modeling
the probability of any sentence it is
now modeling the probability of
say the output English translation
conditions on some input French sentence
so in other words you're trying to
estimate the probability of a english
translation like what's the chance that
the translation is Jane is visiting
Africa in September but conditions on
the input French census like John busy
cooler freak on Sept on so this is
really the probability of an English
sentence conditions on an input French
sentence which is why it is a
conditional language model now if you
want to apply this model to actually
translate a sentence from French into
English given this input French sentence
the model might tell you what is the
probability of different corresponding
English translations right so this is X
is the French sentence zombies equal
frequency long and this now tells you
was the probability of different English
translations of that French input and
what you do not want is to sample
outputs at random if you sample words
from this distribution P of Y given X
maybe one time you get a pretty good
translation jane is visiting Africa in
September but maybe another time you get
a different translation Jane's clearly
visiting Africa in September which is
sounds a little awkward but it's not a
terrible translation just not the best
one and sometimes just by chance you get
study others it's a tempering this
Africa and maybe just by chance
sometimes you sample a really bad
translation African frame welcome Jane
in September so when you're using this
model for machine translation you're not
trying to some poor random from this
distribution instead what you're like is
to find a English sentence Y that
maximizes that conditional probability
so in developing a machine translation
system one of the things you need to do
is come up with an algorithm that
and actually find the value of y that
maximizes this term over here
the most common algorithm for doing this
called the beam search is something you
see in the next video but before moving
on to describe beam search you might
wonder why not just use greedy search so
what a speedy search what greedy search
is an algorithm from computer science
which says to generate the first word
just pick whatever is the most likely
first word according to your conditional
language model could go into your
machine translation model and then after
having paid the first word you then pick
whatever is the second word that seems
most likely and then pick the third word
that seems to most likely and this
algorithm is called greedy search and
what you're reading life is to pick the
entire sequence of words you know y 1 y
2 up to y t y paths there that maximizes
the joint probability of that whole
thing and it turns out that the greedy
approach where you just pick the best
first word and then after having paid
the best first we're trying to pick the
best second word and then after that
trying to pick the best third word that
approach doesn't really work to
illustrate that let's consider following
two translations the first one is a
better translation so hopefully in our
machine translation model it will say
that P of Y given X is higher for the
first sentence it's just a better more
succinct translation of the French
inputs and the second one is not a bad
translations is just more verbose has
more unnecessary words but if the
algorithm has paid Jane is as the first
two words because going is a more common
English words probably the chance of
Jane is going given the French input
this might actually be higher then the
chance of Jane is visiting given the
input sentence input French sentence and
so it's quite possible that if you just
pick the third word based on whatever
maximize
is the probability of just the first
three words you end up choosing option
number two but this ultimately ends up
resulting in a less optimal sentence in
the less good sentence as measured by
this model for P of Y given X I know
this was maybe a slightly hand wavy
arguments but this is an example of a
broader phenomenon where if you want to
find the sequence of words y 1 y 2 all
the way up to the final word that
together and maximize the probability
it's not always optimal to just pick one
word at a time and of course the total
number of combinations of words in a
English sentence is exponentially large
so if you have just 10,000 words in the
dictionary and if you're contemplating
translations are up to ten words long
then there are ten thousand to the ten
possible sentences that are ten words
long picking words from vocabulary size
of from dictionary size of ten thousand
words so this is just a huge space of
possible sentences and it's impossible
to enumerate them all which is why the
most common thing to do is to use an
approximate search algorithm and what an
approximate search algorithm does is it
will try it won't always succeed but it
will try to pick the sentence Y that
maximizes that conditional probability
and even though it's not guaranteed to
find the value of y that maximizes this
it usually does a good enough job so the
sunrise in this video you saw how
machine translation can be posed as a
conditional language modeling problem
but one major difference between this
and the early language modeling problems
is rather than wanting to generate a
sentence at random you maybe want to try
to find the most likely English sentence
the most likely English translation but
the set of all English sentences of a
certain length is too large to
exhaustively enumerate so we have to
resort to a search algorithm so of that
the
go on to the next video where you
learned about the beam search arrow